hello and welcome to this video playing
I am jug you later have no name the
Queens gambit accepted yeah I believe me
for his best button I don't know that
well so I'm sticking with this yeah what
to do now I don't want to play that lame
d take c5 even though it's not a bad
line i recently read that this is
supposed to be not too bad so let's try
this try something else we just takes it
oh okay i didn't expect that one but of
course why not yeah that's developed
maybe I can do something against this a
porn queen to a 1mm might be sure sorry
my rook is not trapped or anything
important so maybe this keeping
everything under control oh it's very
relaxed about everything it just gives
me that porn so maybe yeah maybe
possible what's the dealer says
something I don't quite get it Bishop c6
or what's the point or maybe just he
just claims compensation for I know
because of the bishops or something like
that it's possible maybe
still a bit surprised that he so
willingly um give up the pawn yeah yeah
he's somewhat active hmm yeah I take
here Bishop e2 he has good chances to
just I can take our three and play the
opposite colored Bishop stuff yeah well
team hmm it's it's relatively draw a
sham Queenie five maybe it's also equal
it's also quite equal maybe this in
Bishop f3 and also doesn't do much room
yeah
yeah it's nothing nothing special really
here you can go Bishop f3 or is he
playing more ambitiously between your 25
head doesn't make much sense i can take
it is going to play with sugar 3 I guess
very ambitious player should be glad
that is not just a pawn down bit
surprised him can still take a three and
probably yeah and try to hold this with
some good chances to a world full of
course ok so I'm going to try to invade
on 27
check yeah so say any any idea for Batum
quite difficult
yeah we'll see I'll just just do do
things I do what I can do here which is
not much but let's see if he is how is
defending that same I don't think that
he's doing a good job up to this point
ok so after if five he just goes to just
sell them home oh yeah I wonder there's
something else that I can try I can do
f5 but and not it's not helping yeah I
got to e5 you can go to he goes to g7
and just basically stays I can go f5 no
but I can prepare it still ok let's try
a five
and I maybe should be doing something my
idea is to take him then swing over get
the barn and I get the point here we go
so maybe here on the seventh okay it's
got Luke coming over rook f6 check check
let's see how to do it time morning
maybe this one check okay
black resigns Jim you should probably
hold the ending I was surprised by a
couple of decision heat decisions he
gave up that a porn very willingly
probably yeah probably this isn't so
terrible because well he has some
compensation there with two bishops
definitely an idea for this I think good
move and here I really don't have much
one reason is that he cannot basically
always take on f3 and go into the
opposite colored bishops position which
isn't much I mean this is X what we had
in the game here I was surprised that he
played Queen 35 I was thinking just
takes but okay probably he can't play it
hmm okay the computer um wants to do
this it's an interesting that's actually
quite interesting now I'm threatening
this that's good strong Jack especially
because of this and now black more or
less has to take which gives me night
against bishop and this is not so dry
now very good line okay i just saw this
and now he decided to defend this ending
which is jack not much fun but okay it's
what you have to do and i don't think
you should lose this but he gave me some
activity and from here it gets I think
quite critical f5 now could have done it
immediately but now I five this is
getting getting dangerous now definitely
I have my doubts maybe you can still
defend but it's um it's difficult now
it's two pawns and they H Kornegay porn
they are very hungry far apart so one
yeah I think this will be difficult to
difficult to hold that helped of course
but I don't think you can can avoid the
subject of them okay thanks for watching